non ce n'était pas le radeau de la
méduse ce bateau qu'on se le dise au
fond des ports il au fond des poches il
naviguait en père peinard sur la grand
mare les canards et saph les copains
d'abord les copains d'abord
c'est fluctuat nec mergitur c'était pas
de la littérature
n'en déplaise aux jouteurs le sort aux
jouteurs de sautes son capitaine et ses
matelots n'étaient pas des enfants de
[ __ ] mais les amis franco de port des
copains d'abord c'était pas des amis le
luxe d petit castor et pollux des gens
de sodome et gomorrhe sodome et gomorrhe
c'était pas des amis choisis par
montaigne et la boétie sur le ventre il
se tapait fort les copains d'abord
c'était pas des anges non plus
l'évangile il n'avait pas lu mais il
sait mais toutes voiles dehors toute
voix de lover jean kerprat et compagnie
cette leur seule vitamine leur gré de
leurs confites heures aux copains
d'abord
au moindre coup de trafalgar c'est
l'amitié qui s'aiment ils car c'est elle
qui leur montre le nord leur montrer le
nord et quand il était en détresse
l'arbre a lancé des espèces on aurait
dit les sémaphores les copains d'abord
au rendez vous des bons copains n'y
avait pas souvent de la faim quand l'un
d'entre eux manquait d'abord c'est qu'il
était mort oui mais jamais au grand
jamais son trou dans l'aube se refermer
cent ans après coquin de sort
il manquerait encore des bateaux j'en ai
pris beaucoup mais le seul qui ait tenu
le coup
je n'ai jamais virer de bord mais virer
de port la vie qui est en père peinard
sur la grand mare des canards et
s'appeler les copains d'abord les
copains d'abord